[Applaudissements]
bienvenue au Château de Stéphane Bern
je suis heureux de vous accueillir
entrez mon prince
bonsoir Émilie bonsoir à tous je suis à
vrai dire entouré de deux gares du corps
et il a fallu batailler pour pénétrer
sur le plateau quel est le problème
exactement monsieur nous sommes ici pour
surveiller le bijou de la dame
non pour en prendre soin aussi ah voilà
se laver avec une casserole c'est ça
faire chauffer de l'eau et après bah
comme un ancien temps enfin voilà on se
verse l'eau chaude sur sur le corps et
avec un petit gant on se lave pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'heure du pain c'est l'heure du bain
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en fait pour Macron il y a belle vie
hein
j'ai regardé Macron il est là pour aller
boire un petit verre au bord il est là
pour faire un petit voyage
il est là pour faire tout mais nous on
le demande des choses il est pas là
il vit pour les riches et pour les
pauvres il est pas là bon moi je trouve
ça formidable en fait ça parce que c'est
la France
il a semblé nationale a étendu
l'interdiction de fumer dans tous les
bois et forêts il faut encore que député
et sénateurs s'entendent sur une version
définitive du texte je dis pas que tout
le monde est comme ce monsieur mais je
dis que beaucoup de gens qu'on entend
jamais pense comme ce monsieur et
évidemment ça pose un problème on peut
avoir un jugement de dire mais il dit
n'importe quoi il est ceci il est cela
mais il le pense
pas souvent mais Pascal
c'est pas les mêmes périodes il se passe
pas les mêmes choses même si on est
privé de certaines choses
il faut quand même rester raisonnable je
trouve que c'est accessible dans une
société où il y a plus rien pour nous
donc au final c'est normal que les gens
ils se sentent rejetés
voilà ce que ça donne à la sortie de
Sciences Po certains ont présenté le
vendeur d'autres ont été ministre mais
ça vous tenterait mais pour l'instant je
ne sais pas je pense que je vais avec
les années les expériences qui vont
venir la voix s'il faut la choisir il
faut la choisir assez rapidement parce
que les cursus sont quand même pas les
mêmes non plus au bout d'un certain
temps c'est vrai mais je pense plutôt
dans l'intérêt du côté du journalisme et
pour dire la vérité aux gens quoi
[Applaudissements]
elle pose face à l'indifférence générale
des photographes
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait aujourd'hui
les donneurses et les receveurs doivent
correspondre en termes de couleurs de
peau et de couleur d'yeux bon bah déjà
ça ça donne lieu à un traitement
administratif absolument raciste
j'ai fait j'ai envie de manger mais je
peux pas manger parce que j'ai mal à la
gorge
attends attends
[Musique]
ça veut dire que dans les faits
aujourd'hui les personnes non blanches
les personnes racisées
ont des délais d'attente pour bénéficier
de la PMA qui sont deux trois fois plus
longs que celles des personnes blanches
souvent je me dis mais qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait dans notre société pour
en fait c'est du charabia évidemment
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait tous
collectivement pour arriver à se
renversement des valeurs ou ces gens
comme Adèle qui avait d'ailleurs
sûrement un talent de comédienne et un
espace aujourd'hui et soit entendu alors
justement j'ai un problème parce que je
vous explique ce week-end je pars à
Cannes donc là ça va j'ai pas trouvé à
Canne pile j'ai pris à Nice mais ça va
je m'en suis tiré j'ai un problème pour
le Grand Prix de Monaco je n'ai pas de
logement
n'hésitez pas c'est pas l'argent c'est
que tout est complet les gens réservés
un an à l'avance donc si quelqu'un a un
bon plan à Monaco voilà pour le 27 28
je sais absolument pas à quoi m'attendre
comment je vais revenir cette opération
à tout moment je ne peux plus parler
donc du coup je prépare quelques audio
qui fait ça pour leur demander deux
trois petites choses un vrai qui fait
qui fait des mémos quand il est pas là
pour continuer à saouler les gens ça
n'existe pas je trouve ça très très
malin si vous avez l'Ermitage ou le
voilà l'Hôtel de Paris à Monaco je suis
le président
je suis invité mais je n'ai pas les bons
plus plus concret les prix vont-ils
enfin baisser au supermarché il est très
rapidement le petit garçon se rend
compte qu'au final il a pas perdu son
téléphone mais qu'on le lui a volé et la
ni une ni deux Eric prend son mégaphone
il demande au supporter marseillais de
l'aider
virale en quelques secondes une cagnotte
est improvisée des dizaines de personnes
8 ans des billets
[Applaudissements]
téléphone oui en 10 minutes il a récolté
500 €. donc il y a de quoi s'acheter un
nouveau téléphone effectivement donc
c'est génial oui
j'aurais plus en sous-vêtements
à part si je suis payé
c'est que je t'ai même pas fait hier